foreign
[Music]
for Thursday January 12th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
as you may know deep fakes are media
that has been generated or edited by
artificial intelligence to make it look
like someone said or did something they
never did
they're showing up everywhere and
getting better all the time
here's a clip of a deep fake commercial
from the real estate investment startup
re-alpha oh hello it's your favorite
chick bro Elon here disrupting bubble
baths kind of like how raking that ad
featured an imitation of Elon Musk made
with AI and the technology capable of
doing this is becoming more accessible
it underpins popular apps like text
generator chat GPT and the Avatar maker
lens up now Regulators in China are
taking the first steps to try and
restrict the production of deep fakes
and Regulators around the globe are
watching to see how well they can pull
it off with me to discuss this is our
reporter Karen Howe hi Karen thanks for
joining me thanks so much for having me
Zoe so can you start off by telling us
about these new rules what do they do so
these rules are basically an attempt to
try and curb all kinds of generative AI
tools which is a broad category of
different types of AI software that are
using AI to synthesize or edit audio
video images text and chat based systems
and these tools are also capable of
generating deep fakes alongside more
entertainment or commercial like
purposes and so the government is
essentially trying to say that when you
use these tools to generate
hyper-realistic things that could fool
people people you are going to have to
label them and if you are trying to
maliciously spread fake news that is now
illegal
it's part of a broader effort by Beijing
to tackle what people see on the
internet right
exactly so we have to remember in the
China context censorship is a big thing
and whenever there is a new form of
emerging media anti-fix is one of those
new emerging forms it's trying to extend
its existing very intense censorship
regime to a new form of media so it's
telling people now that we see deep
fakes this is how all of the internet
platforms should be handling it they
should be trying to get rid of it or
they should be labeling it to make sure
that it is in alignment with the type of
information and content that the
government wants to see on the internet
so in on one hand it's not really
surprising because Chinese government
has always taken this very heavy-handed
approach to censoring Free Speech but on
the other hand it is still an
interesting rule that we should be
looking at outside of China because it's
clear that China has been following the
global debates around deep fakes and
around how it could fuel misinformation
and it has a adopted within its rules
some of the emerging best practices
around labeling for handling these
things and so it's sort of like a large
case study now on the types of
Provisions that other Regulators in the
EU or the US are considering right now
in terms of how such labeling Provisions
could be implemented how they could be
enforced and what kind of impact they
might have on businesses
back to that Global implication in a
second but
are applications that are based on this
kind of AI that we're more used to say
here in the U.S something like open AI
or lensa which we've covered on the show
before can you tell us about some of the
applications that do this in China that
might be subject to these rules
yeah so we have lens over here Baidu has
something similar I do is basically
China's major search engine but it also
does a whole host of other things like
it also has its own self-driving car
division similar to alphabet and in the
last year or two years while there's
been a generative AI explosion in the US
there's been a similar situation with
Baidu and other Chinese companies
building things like Avatar generators
or text generators or painting
generators that are more in the style of
like Chinese paintings for example so it
could impact these companies but these
companies the larger tech companies have
already been quite careful in making
sure that they aren't generating
sensitive content because they know the
rules of the game they anticipated that
this would become an issue so actually
what might happen more is that external
generative AI tools outside of China
that don't have the same limits or
restrictions they're going to start
seeing their outputs taken off Chinese
platforms or labeled by the Chinese
platforms when they cross into sensitive
territory how difficult though is it
going to be for Beijing to enforce these
rules
it's a really big question and that's
sort of what I think a lot of China
Watchers and Tech policy Watchers
outside of China are going to wait and
see because in general outside of China
deep fakes part of the reason why it is
so hard to regulate is because there's a
big question mark around enforcement but
traditionally some of those questions
around enforcement are more difficult
because platforms are trying to strike a
balance between free speech and
moderation whereas in China that balance
is not being struck it's just there's
always a leaning more towards censorship
when something might be in violation so
it's possible that it could actually be
really easy to enforce in that they just
get rid of a lot of content or we might
run into other problems that were
unanticipated let's talk about other
governments you may be watching what
happens with China and its rules I mean
are there plans elsewhere in the world
to take steps similar to this
so the U.S has been certainly debating
how to regulate deep fakes but at least
at the federal level there really hasn't
been much progress because of this
really strong concern about violation of
free speech there has been some
regulations or laws implemented at the
state level that ban deep fake use in
very specific instances in the EU there
is other efforts that are further along
in terms of specifically just including
the word deep fake and that language
into regulation but one of the issues
with Democratic environments is that you
can't specify Banning fake news which is
essentially the language that Chinese
regulation uses because if you specify
fake news without defining what fake
news is that basically gives authorities
wide latitude to take whatever speech
they want offline by just claiming that
it's fake news and that is essentially
the Chinese context now so with the EU
regulations say is essentially we
strongly recommend that platforms take
down deep fakes that might fuel
misinformation but there isn't really
significant teeth to that kind of
provision so having to be very very
careful with their language that's our
reporter Karen Howe Karen thanks for
joining us thanks so much for having me
Zoe and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]
[Music]